find these a little male recording they  do this Chile's real kissing the male  uses his front legs to each other the  female when he called her general  perfume  so they're chillin kissing right now the  male is massaging the females mouthparts  with his mouth parts that horn pumping  he's getting ready to deposit his sperm  anaphor and then he's going to try to  drag her over it and she she has to  accept it she can refuse to accept it in  which case this courtship is just for  nail right that little see this little  arm oh I think I see just for metaphor  she's over it but I don't think she's  taken again she didn't she didn't take  it  well that's the thing if there isn't the  female can reject the male and almost at  any stage now she's trying to Club him  guys look at this she's trying to push  him away and this / metaphor is that  tiny tiny little stock if you see right  there on the rock it's much bigger as  much bigger and bigger soybeans  you